what up space fam goals in here from
anime up pro back at it again to discuss
the latest
craziest one piece chapter and i gotta
say this one
was filled with many many great parts
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you enjoy seeing these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is smash that like
button and share this video with any
cultured pirates that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you impatiently wait
for the next chapter to drop you can
check out my brand new podcast called
the dragon ball virgin where my friend
who doesn't watch
anime at all and i will discuss each arc
of the famous series
from start to finish on a weekly basis
it's on spotify apple podcasts and
wherever else you listen to podcasts and
you'll also be able to experience it
live at 4pm eastern time
every wednesday on the rank cafe twitch
channel i'll put all the links to that
and to the one piece version as well in
the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
this chapter is called a lone force so
we're forced to ask ourselves who is
this lone force
and having read the chapter i can say
it's a very very hype long force
but let's continue we start with sasaki
being freed
he was tied up by dengiro but even at
the time
i was like why didn't he kill him i
expected something like this would
happen
and the last thing we need is another
strong opponent to fight
so i really hope denjiro has his reasons
for not finishing him off
when he could have sasaki seems to
address this somewhat
when he says that he was betrayed by one
of his closest friends
so possibly denjiro may have viewed him
as a friend and didn't want to kill him
but still i find it hard to believe that
he wouldn't take him out
considering everything that's at stake
hopefully that close friendship works in
our favor
later on there's also comments about the
damage of big mom's attack
it has incinerated the surroundings even
far from the dome
even sasaki a strong dude himself
comments that her power
since it is able to reach so far is
mind-blowing a sacred tree was taken
down and sasuke was set loose as a
result
again we're seeing how wano and its
culture is being negatively impacted
by the pirate invaders namely kaido and
now big mom
who couldn't care less about anything
sacred to the native people
sasaki says he'll make kyoshiro aka
denjiro
pay for his betrayal but we'll see i
don't think it'll be quite that
straightforward
we then see kaido in his dragon form in
the battlefield which consists of
numbers and sulong minks
jack is there although he's definitely
going down if anyone
is in this battle the red scabbards look
calm cool and collected in the middle of
this war
as kinemon is seemingly about to attack
jack
sulong nekomamushi and inuarashi stop
him they've got this
and you can bet that jack is sweating it
wasn't easy for jack before
to get an upper hand he even played
dirty then now
against the sulong tag team i think this
all-star can say his prayers
it may not be over quick because oda
wants us to savor the revenge
but i think they'll definitely get their
revenge and it will be sweet
then we jump to the other all-stars
namely king and queen
and i laughed out loud during this
conversation as queen is commenting that
these guys were in udon prison
and he doesn't know what happened king
just says and i quote
at this point i've already set my
expectations so low for you
it's hard to get mad when you fail and
quote
that is one of the best lines and
biggest burns
i have ever read this panel perfectly
illustrates the difference between these
two
king is stoic and a man of few words
while queen can't stop talking
and gets easily triggered shocked and
angry not surprisingly queen doesn't
appreciate king's words
then king reaches out to the flying six
as we jump to draken hawkins
drake is pretty much encouraging hawkins
to betray the pirates he joined because
of force
which emphasizes to us at least how he
is an undercover agent who doesn't
really want what's best for the beast
pirates
hawkins comments that the probability of
quote-unquote that man
being alive tomorrow morning is one
percent i'm guessing that that man is
luffy
although that's not confirmed it would
make sense since he's taking on two
yonko and 30
000 men but we all know that oda is not
gonna do us like that
luffy is the protagonist and we all know
he's gonna get the one piece
but stuff like this still raises the
tension the stakes and the eventual hype
of overcoming all odds and hey it isn't
zero percent
too which is a good sign against two
yonko when king speaks
he gives us another huge piece of
information he says that five thousand
intruders infiltrated their banquet of
thirty thousand men
and that this is the greatest failure
since onigashima was founded
again the straw hats are making history
and defying the odds
luffy's influence and bounty and i love
bounties
will grow nicely after this arc there's
no doubt about that at this point i also
love how black maria is just smiling
totally unfazed by the unprecedented bad
news
i'm a big fan of her pun intended king
decides that the infighting is going to
be put on hold
and that even if they catch yamato there
will be no fighting in all-star
now they need to stick together king
thus far has definitely been
coming off as a very formidable villain
and leader i'd love to see a powered up
zorro take him on at some point and we
get ulti
being her lovable blatant and very cute
self
wanting paypay to give her a piggyback
ride and talking back to king
fearlessly king doesn't even bother to
punish such behavior
everyone just accepts that ulti is this
way at this point
she's got a very kawaii dr jekyll and mr
hyde thing going on
with a dino waifu twist king then lets
them know that kaido is on the roof and
their main job is to stop the enemy from
ascending
the castle which kind of totally reminds
me of a mario game where you're trying
to get to bowser
but the point is that means we will get
some epic clashes between the straw hats
and friends who are right now trying to
ascend
and i like how king tells them don't
underestimate them
luffy and his crew are no longer being
slept on even when it comes to higher
ups in the strongest cruise
and that's huge in and of itself i still
remember in the early arcs when our guys
were always
underestimated so to think that we've
come this far
is epic then we jump to who's who
who says he wants to take out queen and
he needs drake's health
drake plays his part well saying he
doesn't want to weaken kaido's forces
and then we jump from this infinitely
interesting combo
to the battlefield where we see more
numbers people straight up can't believe
that creatures can be
this big when they see the numbers they
go for the legs and humans are straight
up
bugs compared to the size of the numbers
the samurai want to clear the way for
the straw hats but these huge numbers
with their huge weapons
are not gonna let that happen as one
swings his huge spike club at our guys
zorro cuts it effortlessly luffy smiles
and jinbei catches the sliced off half
of the club
with one arm this is a great moment
where we get to see how far our crew has
come
luffy mentions that if they were the
same as when they fought oars
they would have had to work together to
take him down but
this time is different he says he
transforms to gear four
and the rest of the crew is smiling
except usopp who is definitely the queen
of the straw hats right here
with his sweaty eye-popping reaction
when hyogoro
sees luffy's form he says it is just
like the wisdom king or buddhist deity i
look forward to seeing the official
translation here
but this definitely seems like a
significant observation we jump scenes
again but i have no doubt at this point
that luffy can take out the numbers by
himself
if he couldn't this would be the
stupidest plan ever
after all then we jump to drake who is
clearly
in pain with bloodshot eyes turns out
queen
and who's who are working together to
question drake
saying that he is the one who helped
trafalgar law escape
this is a possibility that i brought up
before and it would make sense because
drake
as an undercover marine guy would want
to weaken the stronger force as much as
possible
which would be the beast pirates since
kaido has the highest bounty of the
living yonko
it would make sense that military
personnel would do what they can to aid
in his downfall
hawkins seems to be siding with the
beast pirates also saying it had to be
drake
and wondering about his objective i
mentioned before that things were
looking too good for our side
and here we seem to have some pushback
queen and who's who
who might have had beef and hawkins who
might have helped the straw hats
now seem to be solidly working together
as a unified front the infighting and
lack of unity that characterized kaido's
crew
no longer seems to be a big issue when
the chips are down
people seem to be sticking together and
that does not bode well for our forces
but i do love the fact that drake's true
colors are finally out in the open
i've been waiting for this and i'm so
glad it's finally here
queen doesn't know that drake is working
for the marines and drake says he won't
say
anything but queen believes he will when
he gets a taste of torture drake is
quick on the draw though and when he
gets an opportunity he runs he considers
his options
and instead of going back to the marines
he decides that all hope is not
lost he takes down one giant as luffy
takes down another in a cool moment we
get a flashback of
o.g kobe the marine goat telling drake
that luffy is absolutely incredible
people are shocked that a flying sex
member attacked a giant
but drake's focus is on luffy who
appears to represent his hope
he proclaims that he's the lone force
from the title
and wants to fight alongside luffy who
is understandably shocked by this news
first kaido's daughter now flying six
member too i am hella hyped for this
alliance
we got so many epic moments in this
chapter
let me know what you thought of this one
and what you expect to happen next in
the comments
and that is it for this one we had epic
straw hat moments epic king moments
epic drake moments and such a hype
alliance
amazing stuff these chapters haven't
disappointed
and i just see things getting better and
more hyped from here
but anyways if you enjoyed this review
and want to keep them coming then the
best thing to do is smash that like
button and share this video
with any cultured pirates that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos
our nakama is almost 1 million strong
which is awesome to think about thank
you
all and while you impatiently wait for
the next chapter to drop
you can check out my brand new podcast
called the dragon ball version where my
friend who doesn't watch
anime at all and i will discuss each arc
of the famous series from start to
finish
on a week by week basis it's on spotify
apple podcasts
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
and you'll also be able to experience it
live at 4pm eastern time every wednesday
on the rank of a twitch channel
i'll put all the links to that and to
the one piece version as well
in the description i also want to thank
all of you because the channel has been
growing faster than ever
and it's unreal we passed 950 000
subscribers
and are actually approaching 1 million
subscribers and it's all thanks to you
guys
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one-tiered
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate heffa jonathan king rathu
and aura liam thompson
emperor otaku thomas jones ken mono and
admirath
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated overall champion
of the world nothing but a fan king
zeldras anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor hirokami in water bonnie parks
jason wilson florian
joanne garcia steelers mcshamus jessica
kayla fond
deadly saint and stern hawkins thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patreon today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get a name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com anime outpour link in the
description if you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking the blue join button next to
the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you